our investigation of child labor and
African mining focus focuses this
morning on the tens of thousands of kids
growing up literally without a childhood
we showed you yesterday how the mineral
cobalt is most often unearthed in the
Democratic Republic of Congo also known
as DRC many top electronic and electric
vehicle companies need cobalt to help
power their products we spoke with some
of the companies that use cobalt in
lithium-ion batteries all acknowledged
problems with the supply chain but said
they require suppliers to follow
responsible sourcing guidelines Apple is
an industry leader in the fight for
responsible sourcing but it says walking
away from the DRC quote would do nothing
to improve conditions for the people or
the environment Debora patta followed
one young boy home from a mind to
understand the challenges he faces as
his family's provider she joins us from
Johannesburg Deborah good morning good
morning an estimated two-thirds of these
children are not in school they face a
complicated set of barriers including a
weak economy and a corrupt government
but above all poverty ziki Swasey has
never been to school he has no idea how
to read or write but he is an expert in
washing Cobalt
he is one of an estimated 40,000
children in the DRC getting paid a
pittance to produce cobalt every evening
this eleven-year-old returns home with a
dollar or two to provide for his family
I have to go and work there he told us
because my grandma has a bad leg and she
can't so you make the money for the
family there is no one to look after her
he said I am the one who helps it's a
common story in the DRC kids need to
work to survive I feel very bad because
I can see my friends going to school
Dicky told us and I'm struggling
this really is what children should be
doing every child here has been rescued
from the mine and put in a school
receiving a decent education at the Good
Shepherd project sister Katherine root
indi and her colleagues have rescued
over 1,000 children from the mines the
kids who managed to get chair are given
a hot meal and a break from reality how
bad are the conditions in the mines it's
horrible and they know that it is very
dangerous so we have over 100 pounds
total offense in this school and they
have lost appearance some of the
children when they came here they have
gone through accidents broken limbs and
so they know this safe haven is funded
by international charities including US
aid and most recently by a global cobalt
supplier Congo Dongfang mining their
last reported earnings are over 100
million dollars after child mine cobalt
was exposed in their supply chain CDM
donated 71 thousand dollars to this
project and say they've implemented
responsible sourcing guidelines children
here are taking classes but also
learning how to be kids again very
difficult and that is where we begin
actually with the Children's you know
helping them to begin to think about
tomorrow they say tomorrow because they
think of today but tomorrow Fujiki has
to wait when you go to sleep at night
before you go to sleep of that moment
before you fall asleep what do you think
about my son school he answers simply
just a dream for this child
life is very difficult for the children
that we made but sister Catherine is
still hopeful she says within a year she
can already see a transformation in them
these children may be the future but
first they have to realize they actually
have one John Debora patta and South
Africa amazing we just hope Sookie makes
it - yes - the Good Shepherd school and
for companies to say it won't change
anything to pull out because they're
paying them something but to get a
dollar or two dollars a day for the work
that he does and he's just a little boy
just wants to go to school is a
responsibility of these companies and I
would say journalist - the government's
in shambles accused of corruption so I'm
glad we were able to tell their story
it's fantastic storytelling you can see
full replies from some of the companies
who have been connected to the supply
chain on CBS this morning dot-com along
with more video from the investigation